[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquí en visual político ya os hemos
hablado en varios vídeos de cómo
venezuela está atravesando sus horas más
tristes sin embargo nos faltaba por
abordar una de las consecuencias más
graves que está teniendo el gigantesco
fracaso en el que se ha convertido ya la
revolución bolivariana
[Música]
amigos ya no hay duda no hay debate
venezuela está a la deriva cada día que
pasa la vida en este país resulta más y
más difícil y es que claro con índices
de violencia pobreza e inflación
situados entre los más altos del mundo y
con una creciente industria del
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado
campando a sus anchas son muchos
muchísimos los venezolanos que ya no
encuentran más alternativa que poner
tierra de por medio es decir marcharse y
dejar atrás un país que se está viniendo
abajo venezuela tiene la fortaleza
social política militar económica para
caminar con pies propio para vivir en
paz para solucionar sus conflictos para
resolver su problema
normal ante una situación así alguno de
vosotros tendría esperanza yo por lo
menos trataría de escapar por todos los
medios y eso es precisamente lo que cada
vez más venezolanos están haciendo
especialmente los más jóvenes ahora bien
puede que alguno de vosotros se esté
preguntando vale vale alberto pero
exactamente de qué magnitudes estamos
hablando pues fijaos según cálculos de
naciones unidas desde el año 2014 hasta
junio de 2018 alrededor de dos millones
trescientos mil venezolanos ya se han
marchado han abandonado el país si vayan
a hablar de migración todo van a decir
las mismas cifras que se han ido 50
millones ven su lado y todos repiten la
misma cifra y ojo porque los números año
tras año no paran de crecer en otras
palabras la revolución bolivariana se ha
convertido en la causa del mayor éxodo
de la historia de latinoamérica atentos
[Música]
e
que el éxodo
las sociedades son entes en constante
movimiento a lo largo de la historia ya
sea por razones económicas o políticas
las migraciones han sido algo constante
para lograr vivir mejor para huir de una
amenaza o simplemente para escapar de
unas condiciones de vida que no son
buenas continuamente las personas se
mueven de un sitio a otro
[Música]
sin embargo un momento un éxodo es algo
diferente el término éxodo hace
referencia a la emigración masiva de
personas que se ven forzadas a dejar el
lugar en el que viven es decir no se
trata de personas que sueñan con vivir
mejor sino que tienen que marcharse
incluso para poder sobrevivir por lo
general a lo largo de la historia las
causas más habituales han sido los
motivos políticos raciales o religiosos
tal vez el tipo de éxodo más repetido a
lo largo de la historia ha sido el de
personas que se vieron obligadas a
abandonar sus casas porque otro grupo
más fuerte se había hecho con el control
y los expulsaba de forma violenta
ahí está por ejemplo el éxodo del pueblo
armenio en 1915 cuando cientos de miles
de personas se vieron obligadas a
escapar del imperio turco un proceso que
más tarde se ha conocido como el
genocidio armenio otro caso podría ser
el de las decenas de miles de
republicanos que ante la amenaza de
sufrir represalias torturas y condenas
de todo tipo por parte del bando
franquista se vieron obligados a
marcharse de españa tras el fin de la
guerra civil o también lo ocurrido en la
segunda guerra mundial o con las luchas
por la independencia en países de áfrica
y asia en la década de los 60 pues bien
en nuestros días hemos tenido dos casos
dos ejemplos muy claros el primero ha
sido producto de la guerra civil en
siria que desde que comenzó en 2011 ha
producido millones de personas
desplazadas dentro y fuera de sus
fronteras el segundo caso es
precisamente el de venezuela y todo
apunta a que va a terminar siendo mucho
más grande que el decir ya en este
momento la migración de venezolanos debe
ser calificada como una migración
forzada pues no se planifica y es por
supervivencia
beatriz
directora ejecutiva del centro de
justicia y paz y es que amigos es muy
importante entender que está ocurriendo
entender que los cientos y cientos de
miles de venezolanos que están escapando
lo hacen no por gusto sino por necesidad
y es que a diferencia de los ejemplos
que hemos visto el éxodo venezolano no
es fruto de ninguna guerra ni de ninguna
ocupación de alguna fuerza extranjera
sino del hambre el miedo y la miseria
provocada por la revolución bolivariana
según la última encuesta de condiciones
de vida en 2018 el 87 el 87 por ciento
de los venezolanos viven en condiciones
de pobreza y más del 60% en condiciones
de pobreza extrema son números propios
del áfrica sub sahariana lo paradójico
de este caso es que esta catástrofe
humanitaria se produce en una de las
potencias petroleras más importantes del
mundo
amigos la situación está empezando a ser
tan grave que ante la falta de
medicamentos y equipos sanitarios dentro
del país enfermedades como el sarampión
la tuberculosis o la malaria
enfermedades que estaban erradicadas en
este país no sólo han rebrotado sino que
en algunos casos se están convirtiendo
en auténticas epidemias y aún hay más
hay más de 100.000 pacientes con sida en
riesgo debido a la falta de acceso a la
medicación necesaria oficina de las
naciones unidas para la coordinación de
la ayuda humanitaria y es que claro la
falta de medicamentos tiene unas
consecuencias letales sobre la población
pero eso no es todo venezuela vive un
problema de producción y abastecimiento
tan grande que cada vez resulta más
difícil adquirir productos alimentarios
básicos por ejemplo una lata de atún
puede costar más de un salario mínimo de
locos esto amigos es lo que explica que
según datos de naciones unidas mientras
diosdado cabello y los demás gerifaltes
de este régimen están gordos a reventar
de comer langostas sonia alrededor de un
millón y medio los venezolanos que
sufren desnutrición un banquete ético
pantagruélico con la carne que comió
maduro yo creo que como la tropa entera
venezolana una semana no se no se
fagocitó a varias risas así no podría
comer ni siquiera en caracas o de la
carne por supuesto es
incluso para los jerarcas para los
ladrones del rey y luego está la
cuestión de la violencia que tampoco es
ninguna broma las estadísticas de
homicidios por ejemplo se encuentran en
niveles propios de un país en guerra
civil fijaos
[Música]
y luego por supuesto los atracos los
saqueos las extorsiones y todos los
demás delitos que han hecho de este país
un lugar muy peligroso para vivir y
desde luego la policía bolivariana no
ayuda atentos más del 40 por ciento de
los delitos de julio fueron cometidos
por funcionarios policiales observatorio
venezolano de la violencia así que
amigos con este panorama no nos puede
extrañar que tan solo en los últimos
tres años dos millones de venezolanos
hayan abandonado el país por mar aire y
tierra
seguro que todos habéis visto esas
enormes hileras de venezolanos caminando
paso a paso hacia la frontera porque
amigos los que huyen a pie que son la
mayoría a veces toman autobuses
automóviles o mulas pero últimamente son
muchos los que se echan a caminar con la
meta de llegar hasta colombia a brasil y
ecuador en primer lugar y luego tal vez
desde allí alcanzar perú chile o
argentina y desde luego no penséis que
es un viaje fácil para nada la travesía
es difícil no sólo por el cansancio o
por lo que dejan atrás familias amigos
su casa sino que en muchos casos son
víctimas de estafadores ladrones
etcétera por fortuna hasta ahora el
resto de países latinoamericanos han
demostrado una gran solidaridad y han
permitido prácticamente sin
restricciones la entrada a cientos de
miles de venezolanos sin embargo amigos
todo esto podría cambiar recibir a tanta
gente de golpe no siempre es fácil mucho
menos y además los receptores no son
países precisamente ricos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
una enorme presión
amigos es verdad algunos países
latinoamericanos están empezando a
sentir una enorme presión el éxodo de
venezolanos es tan grande que en algunos
casos se enfrentan a verdaderos
problemas de capacidad por ejemplo en el
estado fronterizo de roraima en brasil
el número de venezolanos que asisten a
los centros médicos ha pasado de 700 en
el año 2014 a más de 50.000 en 2017 tan
sólo en los tres primeros meses de 2018
el número ha sido de más de 45.000
cada día pasan 700 u 800 venezolanos por
la frontera y eso está creando muchos
problemas para su vacunación y para la
organización michel temer presidente de
brasil en colombia el número de
venezolanos supera ya ampliamente el
millón de personas en perú son más de
400.000 y en ecuador casi un cuarto de
millón la ola es tan grande que tan sólo
en lo que llevamos de 2018 a ecuador han
llegado más de 4 mil venezolanos cada
día estos y muchos de ellos luego se van
a otros países países como chile que en
los seis primeros meses entre enero y
junio ha recibido a casi 150.000
venezolanos
todo esto está provocando que los países
más afectados comiencen a establecer
algunas medidas para reducir todo este
enorme caudal de personas
por ejemplo ha anunciado el despliegue
de militares en la frontera y ha dicho
que está estudiando establecer cupos es
decir un número máximo de personas que
puedan ingresar al país por su parte
ecuador y perú han comenzado a exigir la
presentación de pasaportes porque pues
porque no es un documento nada fácil de
conseguir en la venezuela de nicolás
maduró por el laberinto burocrático y
por la simple y pura escasez de papel
para poder expedir los
bueno por eso y porque muchos
funcionarios hacen negocios vendiendo a
los en el mercado negro donde un simple
pasaporte cuyo precio oficial es de
apenas 18 con 86 bolívares soberanos
unos 20 centavos de dólar puede costar
entre 700 y 5.500 dólares en función de
la prisa que tengas o del dinero del que
disponga el comprador avalancha de
noticias de informaciones de fax newt
llamadas y verdad face o face yo de
broma hablo español face news
y para los que tengan la suerte de tener
ya un pasaporte cuando esté caduca
pueden prorrogar su vigencia por dos
años más con un sello porque otro
pasaporte desde luego no les van a dar
pero este trámite salvo que acudan al
mercado negro también es bastante lento
puede llevar hasta tres meses
[Música]
amigos de visual política así están las
cosas por primera vez américa latina se
enfrenta a un serio problema en sus
fronteras y no es un problema fácil por
un lado no se puede impedir el paso a
los venezolanos es una cuestión
humanitaria y todavía hay margen mucho
margen pero es evidente que de seguir
así las cosas serán cada vez más los que
traten de escapar del país y eso es todo
un reto aquí es necesario que todos los
países latinoamericanos trabajen de
forma coordinada y reciban el apoyo de
la comunidad internacional el pueblo
venezolano lo merecen eso sí para ser
justos el esfuerzo y la solidaridad
demostrada por muchos de los países de
la región han sido extraordinarios todo
un ejemplo de unidad latina por cierto
un último apunte los venezolanos de a
pie no son los únicos que se están
marchando en los últimos años muchos
venezolanos que hicieron fortuna durante
todo este oscuro periodo de la
revolución bolivariana así
como las familias de muchos altos cargos
se han marchado claro que con la cartera
bien llenas ex ministros de chávez
ocultaron 2.000 millones en andorra el
opulento desembarco en españa de los
millonarios venezolanos una decena de
empresarios y ex altos cargos varios de
ellos detenidos por corrupción han
invertido decenas de millones en casas
de lujo y fincas para cacerías son entre
otros los conocidos como políticos
trataremos de hablar de ellos en un
futuro vídeo pero ahora turno para ti
crees que la comunidad internacional
debe ayudar más al pueblo venezolano
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo darle
al botón de like y no olvides
suscribirte avisa al político un saludo
y hasta la próxima de fax news
llamadas y verdad face o face the global
o español face news un banquete y
pantagruel de con la carne que comió
maduro
yo creo que come la tropa entera
venezolana una semana
[Música]